[Music]
ten-year-old opera singer Iman beitia
leaves us breathless during Tuesday
semi-finals on America's Got Talent
how does it feel Oklahomans crazy
[Music]
Iman's performance got a standing
ovation judge julianne hough was clearly
moved what was like having a front-row
seat to that I literally was like this I
was in awe
she's timeless I said it on stage but
she's an icon at ten years old that you
helping pave the way for many artists to
come
it was crazy you know just like being
there in the moment like you forget
everything else what do your friends and
family make of this whole Danny it's
pretty major what do you want to do
today let's go shopping I'm like okay
and get this Eamon already knows the
band that she wants to collaborate with
most loser bias dang buddy Mon wasn't
the only kid in the spotlight judge
Gabrielle Union wore a very special
dress dedicated to a very special kid
who clearly grew up to be one of her
favorite adults Gabby may may I ask who
who you are wearing literally I am
literally wearing my husband I love it
yeah my young husband are you prepared
if he returns the favor and wears you
all over his clothes as per our prenup
he actually has to once a year you have
to Drake yourself and the other person's
face technicality but if you don't the
kicker doesn't come in so it's severe
worth supercommittee other standout
performers included comedian Jackie
fabulous who didn't hold back joking
about her dating life
Olivia Benson's hardly in season 1 a man
was me it was the wood equals hell no I
had a horrible day it's not horrible but
this one is gonna be a New Deal magician
Dom chambers also left the audience
stunned after he pulled off this trick
featuring a former AGT alum and total
fan favorite
everyone will pick today's big
prediction there's not the big finish
this is the big finish T face was a fan
favorite on a GT how hard was it to book
him 18 mary was gonna be part of it he
was brushing his teeth and I held up a
curtain and he was suddenly on safe so
he didn't have an even have a choice in
the matter to the others now honestly so
take place from New Zealand I'm from
Australia there's a connection there's a
connection there so I not being a fan of
here since I was I think I saw the tape
place show when I was 13 okay back in
Australia seeing him grow made me feel
like maybe I could be doing this too
maybe I didn't to have him in the air
tonight was like this real beautiful
moment
[Music]